Everything happens for a reason. Everything
happens for a reason.
I'm-a tell y'all now what happened to me when I asked myself, "Why
am I here?". I do that every day now: I ask myself, "Why am I here
today in front of y'all."But I'm I'm here today in front of y'all to tell you what happened when I
asked myself "Why am I here?" several years ago. Several years ago I was
on tour with my band Run-DMC.
We was over in Europe. Now, we was in Europe, we was out there
doin' shows we was getting forty, fifty thousand dollars a night.
But for some reason, something in me wasn't right. Had
no idea what it was.
So on this particular evening, after the show, I got back to my room and I asked
myself , "Am I here just to be D.M.C.?" And I
laid there that night, and I thought about everything that happened to me. Okay, I'm Darryl McDaniels.
I grew up in Hollis, Queens, New York. Byford and Banna is my mother and father, my brother
Alfred.
Alfred. Oh, my mother and father worked every day to send me to every school that I went
to, and every school that I went to was a Catholic school that they worked every day to pay for
me to go to, and I treated them right by coming home with straight A's every day. I
was the athletic kid, for me as a kid, every day -- not materially, but every day
as a kid, it was
Christmas for me. Life couldn't be no better than growing up in Hollis, Queens. I met Joe
and ?Jay? and we did things that young ?highs? to do. And then we call ourselves startin' a
rap group and we put a record out, and then the record goes number one, and we, you know, damn near
created hip hop, and we were the first to go gold, first to go platinum, all of
this good stuff: Rolling Stone, MTV, and now here I am, playing in Europe, getting
forty, fifty-thousand dollars
tonight. But why am I so unhappy? I was laying
there and I summed up everything that was mean, I was
unhappy, to the point where I was so depressed.
And out of that, I became very suicidal. Now, I, I, I had
I had suicidal thoughts. I don't think I really would have killed myself, because I did go to the
ledge and look, and I looked and said "I ain't jumping! It's gonna hurt!"
I put the poison in a glass and I thought about drinking the poison, and I looked and said, "I ain't drinkin' that!"
Thought about the gun, the whole nine.
But I knew something was wrong with me,
even though life was good, because I had suicidal thoughts. So
I was sayin', "Okay, I gotta figure out how to kill myself... no, I'm not... whatever, whatever, whatever." But then
I came to the conclusion: I can't kill myself on the road, while we're touring,
because Run and Jay's going to be mad at me. So I'm-a just wait 'til I get
home. So we finish. We did what we had to do on the tour in Europe.
And I came home very depressed, didn't know what this void was in me, because
I summed up everything about me, I'm supposed to be happy. I get in the
car and the limo driver goes, "You wannna turn to... hear some music?" And I'm like, "Yeah, just turn
radio on." "You have a preference?" "No, just turn it on." So he turns the radio on.
And this was in 1997, and on the
radio was a record called "Angel"by Sarah McLachlan.
Now look. Fame, friends, fortune, and even my family, my wife and kids
didn't mean nothin' to me because I was suicidal, I was depressed, I was an
emotional wreck.
But for some reason, when I heard that record Angel, by Sarah
McLachlan, something in me said "Life is beautiful. It's good to be alive."
So, for one whooooole year, all I did
was listen-listen
to Sarah McLachlan's record "Angel."For one whole year. And not only that, I went out
and bought every record she ever made.
And the only thing that I was living for was Sarah McLachlan, over and over and
over, everywhere I went. I was driving my management crazy 'cause I would be like, "Come on, D, we
gotta go on the road. Oh, you gotta put this in."  They would go,"No." I said, "Then I ain't going!" And they would be like,
I said, "Then I ain't going." And they would be like
in for you." And they're like "There's something the matter with you. What's up with this? You're listening to Sara McLachlan," whatever whatever whatever.
So for one year I'm listenin' to Sarah McLachlan. At the end of the year my manager goes,
"Yo, D, I got tickets to Clive Davis' Grammy party." Y'all know who Clive Davis is, right? If you
win "American Idol," you get a deal with Clive Davis; he discovered Janis Joplin and all these people.
But I'm like
I have no time for Clive Davis and Hollywood. Because
I have my Sarah McLachlan. That's all I care about."
So he's like "Yo, D, man, I went through a hard time to get these tickets," the blah blah blah.
I'm looking and OK, I say, "OK. I'll go to the party, but I'm only stayin'
one...hour.
So I go to the party, Clive Davis Grammy part in L.A.. I'm- man, I'm counting the seconds
59, 58... I'm looking around, and there's Stevie Wonder.
??? Alicia Keys,
Alicia Keys...who cares about Alicia Keys... paparazzi and Pam Anderson and
all this stuff, right I'm in there hatin' on everything! So I'm sitting at
a party that I did not want to go to, because all I want to do is listen to my
Sarah McLachlan music. But guess who walks in?
[gasp!]
That lady! She was "that lady" to me. She was "that lady" to me then. That lady
that made that record that changed my life. I'm losing it because nobody in the
whole facility knows I'm an in-the-closet Sarah
McLachlan fan! But I'm losing it! I'm like
"oh my, that's that lady." So I get myself together, I say "OK, I gotta go over there. If I
do die, kill myself, whatever, I gotta go over there and let her know what her record did for me."
So I walk over to Sarah McLachlan I'm in the the whole Run D.M.C. garb, the hat, the black all the way down.
She sees me comin', she goes, "D.-D.M.C.! 'It's tricky
to rock around, rock around,' and 'My Adidas!' and 'Walk This Way!'"
I'm like "Wow." But in my head.
This is where I was at. In my head I'm like
"That's a good reason to stay alive. Because Sarah McLachlan likes my music"
music. That's where I was at, y'all.
I go over to her and I say 'Hey, Miss McLachlan,
I just want to tell you, your record 'Angel,' your record 'Angel' saved my life. I was depressed, I was suicidal,
but every day I listened to that record, I don't leave the house without listening to that record, it's the crutch I stand on. It's
it's like I...I...nev..nev...everything I do revolves around that record. And listen, the record is called Angel, you sing like
like a angel, people say you are an angel, but you you're not an angel to me, you're God." And I'm going on and on and on,
and she's looking at me like
"O...K...???"
Where is this coming from? I just wanted to say hi to his ass."
So I finish my little rap. She looks at me and she goes... she didn't know what to say. "Thank you
Darryl. Because that's what music is supposed to do." Three whole years go by. She
by -- she shakes my hand, walks away -- three whole years
go by. I'm trying to figure out what this void in me, this and that, why do I want to kill myself.
But I ain't gonna kill myself, 'cause I got my Sarah MacLachlan music, I'm listening to Sarah McLachlan and figuring out why am I crazy. Listen, I'm going through a lot
of emotions!
Then I realize something. People know my musical legacy.
What Run-D.M.C. did. First to go gold, first to go platinum, first on MTV
first with a record deal, first- of- all our firsts, but nobody knows the the legacy. Nobody knows
about the little boy Darryl who became D.M.C. so I said, "If I die,
my friends and my fans, and people that I grew up with, my generation,
they just know who D.M.C. what D.M.C did. They don't know about Darryl. And especially the younger generation"
the younger generation. So I said, "I gotta write a book." So I'm gonna write a book, and it's going to be "Yo, What's Up!
my name is D.M.C. you know me Darryl McDaniels of Run-D.M.C., first to go gold first to go platinum, first on MTV
MTV, first on Rolling Stone, all the firsts..." I got to the point where, I got to, I wanted to write "Yeah,
I was born May 31st, 1964..."
When I got to that point, I realized that's all I know about the day I was born. So I said.
"I gotta figure out,
you know, the details of my birth. So I called my mother up: "Hey, Ma.""Hey, Darryl. How you doing?" "Love you.""Love you too. Did
you eat?""Yeah, Mom.""You're losing too much weight!""No, Mom, I'm
working out! It's a difference! But whatever, whatever. I just need to know three things, 'cause I'm writing this book. How
much did I weigh, what time was I born, and what hospital?" She told me those three things. "Love you."
"Love you too." Hung up the phone, boom. About an hour, later the phone rings. It's my mother my and my father.
father. "Hey!""Hey, son, how you doing?" "What's up, Dad, yo, what's up?" "We
What's up dad, yo what's up? Hey we got something else to tell you. Blah-se-blah this, blah-se-blah that, blah blah blah. You was a month old
we think you're Dominican, and you're adopted
you're adopted. You're adopted. You're adopted. You're adopted. You're adopted. You're adopted.
Right then and there, the whole world stopped. "ERRRRT"
Thought about all the Run-D.M.C. stuff, St John's University High School when I was a little kid. And I thought about all that
stuff that I was laying in a, in a bed three years- or I mean couple of years earlier saying "Am I here just to be D.M.C?"
Summed up everything about me. That was the one void, the piece of
the missing link
that had me going out of my mind, suicidal, because that was the one thing I didn't know about myself.
Now. If you think there's really a time to commit suicide, finding out you're adopted
at age 35, and people
and people say, "D, they told you OVER THE PHOOOONE?!"
But right then and there, something happened.
I remember it. Agh. When I asked myself in my head, ?did? D.M.C., and summed it up
That was the missing void, so the void was filled. I REALLY wanted to kill myself, but then I remembered
something.
Sarah McLachlan said that's what music is supposed to do, so I said "OK. Before I get
suicidal, depressed, and do something real crazy, she said that's what music is supposed to do."
I said I need to write a record that's gonna help that little orphan, or that little kid in
foster care who thinks 'They threw me away, I'm worthless. I mean nothing. My mother and father...love you..
Because I may be D.M.C.. But what I really represent is purpose and destiny. So I need to make
to make a record that's gonna inspire somebody the way Sarah McLachlan inspired me.
And I got a bigger idea! [gasp] I'mma call that lady back up.
Have that lady make that record with me." So, get Sarah MacLachlan on the phone and I'm thinking,
"If she thought I was crazy three years ago. She gonna really think I'm crazy now!"
now." "Hey, Miss McLachlan, it's Darryl, remember me?""How could I forget you, Darryl:
you called me God. What do you want?"
want?" Okay, here we go. "Remember when I met you three years ago and I told you what your record did for me?""Yeah." "And then
you looked at me and you told me that's what music's supposed to do.""Yeah." "Well, I ju- I found out why I was so depressed and suicidal, blah-se-blah this,
Blah-si-blah, well, my father told me I'm adopted, I need to make a record that's gonna inspire me the way, um, inspire people the
the way your record inspired me, blah-se-blah, but I, will you help me do this record?"
"She goes "yes", real quick. I was like, "Wow, that was easy."
I'm losing it now! I'm like "She said yes!" This and that, "I'll fly you to New York, put you in the Four Seasons,
studio..." She says "No, Darryl. You can come to my house and make the record."
Now I'm a fan, now, after four years of listening to this lady, I'm a fan, now, right? To make
a long story short, when she said "Come to my house," I fainted.
I woke up, I was in Vancouver, Canada. It's beautiful
there!
At Sarah McLachlan's house, the lady whose record saved my life, right?
Now listen, we went there, I said "Miss, McLachlan. I want to make a remake of Harry
of Harry Chapin's 'Cat's in the Cradle,' and I'm-a put my adoption story there, and I'm-a
give it a happy ending." "Okay, cool." Took us two days to make the record. Now
listen! It all started in a car with her record coming on the radio, right,
A year goes by. I go to a party that I did not want to go to. Who walks in?
Then I find out that I was adopted. I call her up to do the record with me. So we did the record, right?
All happy. I was all my way out the door, she says,
"Darryl! Before you go I gotta tell you something!" Now...
I love her to death, her music, everything, what she did for me: I'm in heaven!
I'm on Cloud Nine! "Whatever it is you want, Miss McLachlan?"
She says, "Before you go, I need to tell you something, Darryl." And I say "What?" She says
"I was adopted, too."
And I did not know that.
Everything happens for a reason.
[Applause]
you.